When you're using your laptop or your
desktop computer, you may find at times
that you are unable to access the
network. If this is because malware is
installed on your system, the malware
itself may be causing this problem,
either intentionally preventing your
access to the network or unintentionally
causing problems with network
connectivity. Malware likes to control
where you go on the network because it
knows that if you download anti-malware
software, you'll probably remove it from
your system. And very often, malware is
using a known vulnerability in your
operating system to gain access to your
data. And if you were to download the
latest OS patch, you would be closing
that vulnerability and effectively
preventing malware from gaining access
to that information. If this is related
to malware, then your best course of
action would be to use a malware cleaner
or even better remove everything on the
system and restore from a known good
backup.
Many browsers will show messages that
have been pushed from a third party
website onto your main browser screen.
And often these might be websites that
are not legitimate. For example, they
might show that your anti virus
subscription has expired and you have to
renew it by clicking on the buttons in
that message. In reality, of course,
these messages are not legitimate. And
by installing anything from these links,
you're effectively infecting your system
further. Most browsers provide options
in the security settings so that you can
define how notifications are brought to
the screen and you can block or allow
certain sites from showing those
notifications on your browser. Very
often, ignoring these notifications is
the best way to proceed. But if you are
concerned that malware might have been
installed onto your computer, it's
always a good idea to run a scan just to
make sure nothing unusual is installed.
Here's a fake anti virus message that
was received on a family member's
computer. It all looks very legitimate.
It tells you at the top that you must
contact us immediately so that our
engineers can walk you through the
removal process over the phone. Your
computer is disabled. And then it gives
information about the problem. It talks
about what virus is identified and gives
you a phone number to call to solve this
problem. In reality, of course, this is
not a legitimate virus. This is a
complete hoax and no software has been
installed onto your computer. In
reality, of course, the only thing this
malware is doing is displaying this
message on your screen. If you were to
delete this executable, you would
effectively be removing this so-called
malware from your system. But if you
call the number, they will entice you to
give them money to unlock your computer
or to subscribe to whatever service they
are supposedly offering. This often
requires some specialized removal
techniques to be able to get rid of this
from your computer completely. In this
example, the best solution might be to
delete everything on your computer and
restore it from a known good backup.
Here's a better view of this fake anti
virus alert. You can see that it looks
legitimate and it tells you that it has
found a number of different viruses.
This one is detected Trojan spywear
known as financer track2.dll.
Normally the information that we are
storing on our computer is safe from
being changed or modified when we are
not using our PC. But unfortunately, you
might find cases where system files
might be renamed or files that you've
previously saved are suddenly not
available where you left them. There
might also be cases where files that
were assigned to only you now have
different permissions associated with
them. Or you may try to access one of
your previous documents and find that
the access is now denied. All of these
are highly unusual, should not be
occurring on a normally running system,
and are almost certainly the case of
malware being installed on this
computer. The best practice, of course,
is to use a malware cleaner or delete
everything and restore from a known good
backup.
It seems that our newest operating
systems are showing us more and more
notifications. Most operating systems
give you a bit of control over what's
shown and you may be able to modify the
notification options on your operating
system. On Windows, you'll find these in
the system app under the notifications
option and you have the choice to enable
or disable all notifications or go into
individual applications and choose which
apps you would like to receive
notifications from. If you turn off all
notifications, you might be missing
important information from your system
services. So, it might make more sense
to control this on an appbyapp basis to
enable or disable exactly what
notifications you'd like to see.
By default, most operating systems will
download updates and install them
automatically when needed. But if you
were to look at Windows Update on your
computer and find that it was not
updating things properly, then you'll
have to do a bit more troubleshooting.
Since all of these are being downloaded
from the cloud, our first step will be
to look at our network connectivity. Do
we have a good connection to the
internet and are we able to download
files from other thirdparty websites? We
might also want to look at any firewalls
or filtering that might be in place just
in case someone has added a new rule to
the firewall that is preventing access
to Windows update. And some environments
are limiting the amount of bandwidth
you're able to transfer through the
network. So you may find that the
updates for the operating system are
simply too large for your existing
network connection. Windows does include
a troubleshooter to look for network
connectivity for Windows update. You can
find this under the settings system
troubleshoot and choose the option for
other troubleshooters to find out what
is happening with your Windows update
process. If it's able to find any
problems, it will identify that it has
detected an issue with Windows update
and it will try to resolve that problem
automatically in the Windows update
troubleshooter.
Pop-up messages in a browser can look as
if a legitimate application is asking
you to perform a function. This is a
very easy way for malware authors to get
their malicious software onto your
computer. Most new browsers will prevent
these random pop-ups by having a pop-up
block feature built into the browser
itself. You could of course disable that
feature, but most browsers will have
that capability turned on by default.
But if you are using a modern browser
and still seeing these messages, this
might indicate malware. So you might
want to perform a scan or delete
everything and restore from a known good
backup.
You've probably found yourself surfing
around the internet and received a
message in your browser that says your
connection is not private or something
very similar to that. This indicates
some type of certificate problem. So we
might have to do a bit more research to
determine why this is occurring. Most
browsers allow you to click or right
mouse click on the lock icon associated
with that HTTPS connection and this will
bring up a view of the certificate on
that system. This provides us with
additional details about the
certificate. For example, who issued the
certificate, when it expires, and more
details about how this certificate was
originally created. It may be that we
are using a different fully qualified
domain name than this certificate was
created for and that creates a mismatch
when you connect to that site. Or it may
be that the digital signature on this
certificate is not from a trusted
certificate authority. And since the
browser doesn't recognize the
certificate authority, it presents you
with a message saying that this is an
untrusted connection. And because the
date and time is important in these
certificates, you have to make sure that
your local computer is also set to the
right date and time to prevent any type
of mismatch between your computer and
the certificate.
A very common problem you might see is
someone who is typing in a Google search
into their browser, but the results that
come up on the next page are not from
Google. This is referred to as a browser
redirection where you are expecting to
go to one website and you end up being
redirected to a completely different
website. This could certainly be related
to a website misconfiguration, but
almost always this is related to some
type of malware. The malware authors are
redirecting you to a site where they're
expecting you to either download
additional malware or present
advertising that they can use to make
even more money. The process for
cleaning this is the same as any other
malware infection. We can use an
anti-malware or anti virus cleaner. Or
even better, we can delete everything
and restore from a known good backup.
One of the most challenging problems to
troubleshoot is someone saying their
system is slow. This could be a problem
with many different resources on this
computer, so it might take some time to
perform troubleshooting. If the issue is
related to browser performance, we might
want to confirm that we are using the
latest browser and that we're up to date
with the latest versions. You might also
want to see how many tabs are open in
any particular browser. The browser on
this screen has almost 30 different
sites that are open. And there's so many
that they're now just a single icon at
the top of the screen in each one of the
tabs. Sometimes cleaning out your
browser can resolve a number of these
performance problems. So, you might want
to go into the cache and the cookies
inside of your browser, clean those out,
delete any of the temporary files that
are in the browser, and then restart the
browser session. You might also want to
look at your task manager to see the
performance of your browser, how much
CPU it's using, how much memory, and if
it's accessing any of your disk, which
certainly could be slowing down the
performance. I visited sites before that
suddenly slowed down my browser to a
crawl. And when I brought up my task
manager, I saw that my CPU utilization
for the browser was at 100%. This was
because this website had a crypto miner
running in JavaScript. When I left that
website page, suddenly my CPU dropped
back down to zero. And it could be that
the issue is related to this specific
type of browser. You might want to have
different browsers installed on your
system so that you could try different
browsers against the same website and
see if you get the same performance
issues.